this is our tool for being able work out
what is the size of an acre
how far is it we're attaining and that's
why it's in the shape of a semicircle
okay yeah
what I'd like you do is to put it on so
you a piece of paper onto your page and
I'd like you to actually just trace it
really really trace out the do they do
remember what is this this is fault yes
it's a protractor right not to be
confused with a pair of compasses which
is the 20 things which you can think
whiteout and smaller these things this
is a pair of compasses by the way it's
not a compass
what's a caucus it's a yes yeah the
compasses me you look at and you pointed
in direction and tells you which bearing
you're on north south east west okay
this is a pair of compasses in the same
way that this is a pair of scissors
right there are two of them fit sir pair
of compasses parros's is what we're
doing
let me draw with me once I get my thumb
disease is a protractor okay now we're
not going to uh we're not going to call
the inspired things but they're just a
couple of pictures on it you'll notice
if you look closely at your protractor I
embarked a tables from zero if we have a
look on the left hand side so boom I put
that down that's a pretty important
number and then if you start from the
left hand side you go all the way over
to the right all the way around it ends
on what my mom's it end up 180 very good
that means if I had to protractors like
this and lay them on top of one another
that then to go all the way around from
the beginning all the way back to the
start what angle would I get if I would
get a circle and what size would have
been what number three
very good okay so if I went all the way
around and get 360 yeah it's an
interesting story as to why we chose 360
seems like a bit of an unusual number
why did we pick that as the number all
the way around we're gonna talk about
that in a loop it's fine this one oh um
had that number you're there now because
you have 0 over here 180 in there what's
right in the middle do you see it there
everybody it's mighty that's an
important table so you want to run for
me but that it is one reference and you
can see if you're measuring from left to
right if I have for instance you don't
need to draw this bit you find an angle
and it's vertex I want to place right in
the middle back one of its arms goes
this way and the other of its arms goes
say what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start from 0 and I'm gonna read the
numbers as they go up until I get to
this one maybe this would be something
like I know what would you guess I got
just just an estimate
yeah or can you give guessing number
what would you think that numbers
roughly oh okay this is interesting
right I'm gonna go with like kinda 120
because you can see maybe a bit less you
can see I went from zero I went all the
way up to 90 and they're never gonna be
past that haven't I haven't gone all the
way to 180 but I'm definitely going
there so it's somewhere between their
question okay so I'm so glad you asked
that because we're not quite finished
drawing the feature that's a protractor
right do you've noticed we've been
starting from the left so the zero there
and then it goes all the way around to
180 on the price but if you look closely
you will see there's another set of
numbers on the either side of the
protractor to notice that so we call
these they are the outer track and is an
inner track then it spits important to
draw and stone on the inside of this
outline would you draw from these this
other track that goes on the inside of
the projector okay question yes
okay that's it so talk about that that's
okay everyone's got their individual
preferences now I only started with the
outside track because well it goes from
that's right and I usually read from
left to right okay
but see where I put my reading with you
right I've got one of these herbs going
off here to the left what is my arm
started however on this side right
once my arm is over here okay now I'm
here if i hunger for another anymore in
let's say what is on something like this
so important that you always bring that
vertex that what is the point do you put
it right in the middle what you heard
about the middle now you can see for
this blue angle it's not a good starting
from this area is it right like my angle
doesn't have anything to do with the
side everything's happy to go over here
so I want you to notice on the inner
track there is another number zero here
and then it goes all the way up to nine
again and has 180 over there so do not
confuse which side which I was going
with which right the inside track starts
with zero there so that's where you have
one of your arms and then you measure up
I'm guessing that'll be something like I
don't know maybe 30 degrees or something
like that you have a look at um how far
you get how big that angle looks like so
I guess in summary and maybe you ever
put this down underneath right you have
a track
it's where the arm is going to the left
right
if the other stars on the left then you
want the zero to be on the left right
for the image track you do it the
reverse the inner tracker you can see in
blue there is where my arm starts
nominal metric on the right if my arm
starts on the right then I want zero on
the right because that's where I figured
okay does that make sense
all right now we're gonna be doing a bit
of measurement today I'm an interesting
thing is that most people say oh but but
I'm on a computer screen or I've got a
textbook and won't it look different so
that's why I taught this do I want you
to get out you'll move on if you don't
have a straight edge I cannot lend you
some in a second but just what you don't
look at it for a moment if actually can
I borrow someone's rule off yeah British
yeah that's perfect
detective thank you
okay see the business and what I want
you to imagine is that relation I
sitting next to each other right and we
are both trying to measure a particular
angle okay now British might be looking
at his own laptop of soon like that and
his angle might be say he's big
okay so in his textbook corney's
computer on the screen make your ish
that's for you that's how big the size
of his angle is okay but me you might be
able to tell my eyesight is not the
greatest okay so I went on my screen
I've zoomed in really really far and so
my angle doesn't look like that my Eagle
looks like this
okay stay
okay now here's the cool and interesting
thing right angles think back to our
first lesson yesterday on this right
angles are measuring the size of
measuring the size of what we're a
visual use size of like yeah a kid so it
is it is to do it then you could see it
with your hands right when you draw the
argue it's like this pot here or this
part here okay but an important thing is
like these angles like actually about
this size of the turn or the size of the
rotation okay so if I took a small rule
on actually yes I'm gonna use a deal and
I rotate it a little bit right I rotate
my big rule off by the same amount to
make this angle so even though this
angle looks enormous right it's bigger
in centimeters right but it's exactly
the same size in degrees so you can zoom
in or out of all the diagrams until we
can under screen and you'll still get
the same angular size I guess you would
use whatever size is appropriate feel
contracta okay I think your projector
should fit on your screen pretty